what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight plot leaked video today I will be
reading season 8 episode 3 to be honest
with you I don't even want to waste my
breath on anything else because this
episode is so awesome it's emergency
awesome let's just get right into this
undi bunka baletta sowed season 8
episode 3 starts with a cold opening at
the karhold they will show the castle
and land completely destroyed everything
is in ruins with smoke rising from piles
of rubble acres of land are soaked in
blood with pieces of clothes and
uniforms and broken weapons everywhere
it will look like a typical battlefield
the only difference is there are no
bodies anywhere the next scene is in
Winterfell it will be a long shot that
pans around the outside of the castle
showing all the preparations being made
for the Great War outside of the main
wall deep trenches were dug that makes
it appear to be a moat The Hound torment
and a few others are carrying barrels of
pitch to fill the trenches when the
battle begins it will be caught on fire
it will basically enclose Winterfell in
a ring of fire to prevent the dead from
entering the castle there are hundreds
of archers on standby at the top of
Winterfell wall there are barrels lined
up every 10 feet they are being filled
with arrows that have tips made of
dragonglass down in the yard stacks and
stacks of Spears are being piled up all
of them have dragonglass tips as well
grey worm is in the yard and his spear
looks slightly different than the rest
his was made out of the red dragon glass
Gendry made himself a new hammer the
head has several spikes all made of
different color dragonglass black red
and green John Sansa Arya and ghost are
walking around the courtyard overlooking
all of the work and preparations being
made Arya tells them about her run-in
with Nymeria in her pack
she says she won and I Mariette to come
home with her but deep down she knew she
was meant to be in the wild but she does
hope to see her again John looks at
ghosts and he almost appears said now
that Ghost is the only direwolf in
Winterfell John tells Arya they were
meant to have these wolves as long as
they are alive they will always have a
connection
he also says even when him and ghost are
apart
he always has a sense that he is near it
Arya says I know exactly what you mean
as John Sansa and Arya are walking
around the courtyard a few of the guards
begin to yell down to them they tell
John that a rider is approaching the
gate
beric Dondarrion has arrived at
Winterfell
he looks like he's about to collapse but
John tells the men to open the gate and
allow him inside
when Arya recognises him she pulls out
her dagger she tells him he has come to
the wrong place John seems confused Arya
says he is the man that sold Gendry to
the red witch she swore she would kill
him if she ever saw him again
berrak says kill me if you must but I am
here to play my part John the night King
and the army of the Dead will be here
tonight you're on in the golden company
arrive at King's Landing Cersei Qyburn
and the mountain are outside waiting for
them to unload you're on greed Cersei by
grabbing her by the hand and giving it a
kiss he says I have completed every task
you have set upon me I have travelled
the seas and conquered your enemies now
I have brought you a brand new army
Cersei says you haven't defeated all of
my enemies but perhaps you should be
rewarded the commander of the golden
company tells Cersei it feels good to be
in Westeros Cersei says don't get too
comfortable we have a war to win the
commander wishes to speak with whoever
commands her troops Cersei says she is
in the process of finding someone she
can trust to command her Lannister men
her former commander Jaime has left the
city he went to go join his traitor
brother that bastard in the north who
dares to call himself King in that
foreign [ __ ] with the dragons she says
it doesn't matter now I have everything
I need right here
Euron has the biggest smile on his face
although Circe wasn't just talking about
him Circe notices the commander of the
golden company got tense when she
mentioned the dragons
Cersei says what's wrong are you afraid
of dragons the commander says I wasn't
sure if they were real I have only heard
about them but I have always wanted to
see one Circe says don't worry you will
see them and you will help me kill them
all of them along with my trader
brothers the bastard Jon Snow and that
wretched [ __ ] Daenerys Targaryen you're
on wishes to speak with Cersei alone he
looks at the mountain while saying this
Cersei says as you wish follow us to the
red keep in the next scene Theon and his
small group of Ironborn men laying back
on Dragonstone now that everyone went
north the island is pretty much
abandoned vielen brought his men here to
feed them and make sure they find enough
weapons to arm themselves he now knows
he will need to board the silence in
order to get Yara back when night falls
they plan on heading to King's Landing
in hopes of getting her back without
everyone in this city being alerted
while he is trying to locate her back in
Winterfell
Brian Sam Tyrion and the maester enter
the godswood
Tyrion says there must be something or
someone connected to all of the legends
the book about the long night talks of
azor Ahai and Melisandre talks about
there being a prince that was promised
and Brian says old name used to tell him
stories about the last hero all of these
legends are said to have faced the
darkness in one sam says bran we need
you to see if there is anything else you
can tell us about this man who was he
how did he end the long night brain
takes a deep breath and his eyes rolled
back into his head bran is about to see
another series of visions some past some
present in some of the future the first
thing he sees is a black silhouette
standing on a battlefield he is holding
a red sword it's just like his previous
vision but this time the black
silhouette is standing face-to-face with
the night king then he sees the same
battlefield but this time no one is
there the snow is gone bran is walking
he sees a man facedown in the water with
red rubies all around him then he sees a
crowd of people
cheering there is a man mounted on a
horse the man leans down and hands
something to a woman in the crowd goes
eerily silent then bran is at the wall
and there is a pool of blood in the snow
when Brian looks into the blood he can
see blue rose petals scattered
throughout it soaking up the blood bran
is then back at the Tower of joy but
this time Liana is sitting up on the bed
bran can hear the man say he will be the
song of ice and fire bran can see a
woman dressed in red with hair as red as
the bleeding star it looks like she is
talking to someone but he can't quite
make out who the person is
it sounds like John's voice but all he
can see is a black silhouette was steam
rising from his sword then Bryan is back
on the battlefield
covered in snow bran can see the man
that looks like a black silhouette
holding a red sword clenched in his fist
the man is face-to-face with the night
king the night King steps forward in the
black shadow swings his sword as fast as
lightning strikes but Bryan comes out of
his vision before he can see what
happens when Bryan opens his eyes he is
completely covered in sweat he was
gripping his chair so hard his hands are
sore in red Tyrion Sam and the maester
are looking at him anxiously awaiting to
hear what he has seen
Tyrion says or the legends true sam says
do you know what we need to do to defeat
the night king bran says yes now it all
makes sense I was wondering why the
three-eyed raven showed me the tower but
now I know bran then looks at the
maester and says take me to Jon as bran
is being pushed across the courtyard he
spots Jon Daenerys and several other
main characters when Jon sees bran
coming across the yard he can tell
something is wrong
Jon walks over to meet bran halfway
several people have crowded around to
see what's going on bran says Jon it's
time we talk We Need to Talk alone Jon
says we can go down into the crypts as
they begin to head that way men shout
down from atop the walls they tell Jon
more riders are approaching the gate
this time there are hundreds before Jon
can even ask who it is men begin to pick
up their weapons and draw back their bow
he can hear people shouting every other
word is a curse
along with the name Kingslayer Jaime
Lannister and bran have arrived and
there are men wearing frayed uniforms
Jaime managed to round up a few hundred
soldiers that were still scattered
around the twins
Tyrion can't believe Jamie has rode to
Winterfell but he takes note that he
isn't wearing the Lannister colors nor
does he have any Lannister men with him
something must be wrong Jaime and Bronn
are greeted was zero courtesy songs and
demands to know what the hell was going
on and why Jamie is here with men
displaying the phrase sigil men from
above begin to scream Kingslayer the
north were members you made a mistake
coming here
Jon attempts to quiet the shouts he asks
Jaime where the rest of the men are the
ones that Cersei promised to provide
before Jaime can answer songs and
notices the sword Jaime has she says it
was Joffrey's wedding gift from Tywin
she says Jon that his father's sword
it was made from ice Brienne begins to
panic
so she steps in between them she says
lady Sansa
Jaime is no longer the man he once was
he saved my life
he also sent me to save yours he gave me
this sword to protect you he told me to
use Ned Stark's sword to protect Ned
Stark's daughter
Jaime interrupts and says I have come
here to help then Jamie pulls out widows
wail in a hundred swords of the north
are pulled on Jaime someone shouts go
ahead Kingslayer give me a reason to
kill you where you stand
Jaime says you can have the sword but I
was hoping I could use one to help you
defeat the dead I know the Lannisters
are no friends of the Starks I know I
have done things that I wish I could
change but I can't all I can do now is
be a man of my word and I remember
promising to help you in this war Cersei
is not coming so I left her Joran lied
he wasn't going back to the Iron Islands
right now he is picking up 20,000 men
from the golden company Cersei plans to
use them to defeat whoever survives in
the north
including me now when Daenerys here
Cersei lied she gives Tyrion of venomous
look Varys puts his head down and he
walks away John looks at Jamie and says
I don't like you sir but I believe what
you have said he motions to Jaime and
Bronn and tells them to come inside but
he tells all of their men to wait
outside of the gate they are not to
enter the castle until everything is
sorted out in the next scene you're on
Cersei and the mountain entered the
chambers to talk in private
you're on once the mountain to step
outside but Cersei tells him not to
worry he won't tell anyone
Euron begins pressing the issue of
getting what he feels is owed to him
which is Cersei he tells her how he is a
better man than Jaime and how he won't
be coming back now unless his head is on
a spike Cersei continues to play
hard-to-get but eventually urine starts
to get her to soften up some Cersei
knows what you're on once but she tells
him she is pregnant with Jaime's child
inside of her
Euron doesn't really care if she's
pregnant he says all he's ever wanted
was to marry the most beautiful woman in
the world
he is the king and he deserves to have a
queen at his side he says they should
roll Westeros together he will never
betray her or abandon her in a time of
need and like Jaime did they will
conquer all of their enemies together
Cersei enjoys the attention he is giving
her but she isn't ready to hand over the
keys to the kingdom
but she does reassure him that in due
time he will get everything he needs
Cersei then motions for the mountain to
step outside Cersei closes the door
behind him then she takes Euron by the
hand and walks him over to the bed back
at Winterfell
everyone is gathered in the main hall
Lord Glover and Yan Royce are the
loudest voices in the room they are
outraged at the sight of the Kingslayer
they warn Jon that if they allow this
man to make camp in the north he will
slit their throats while they sleep you
cannot trust a Lannister Brienne and
Tyrion both tried to subdue the tension
in the room by explaining how they need
to help and how Jaime wouldn't have
dared come here in the midst of war
under ill intentions Lord Glover
threatens to take the Knights of the
Vale home he will not have his men
fighting alongside sir Jaime Lannister
this causes other men to begin to stand
up and say they are marching home as
well
they will wait out the storm in their
own lands that's until John slams his
fist into the table and says enough John
says I told everyone I would not force
them to stay and fight but if you leave
and run home and decide to face the dead
alone you will die the only way we have
a chance of surviving is by staying
together that is the only way John says
I have no love for the Lannisters they
are responsible for murdering my father
my brother and Lady Stark I want him
here no more than any of you but we need
men I have came face-to-face with the
night came you do not know what he is
capable of you haven't seen the army of
the Dead but soon enough you will and
you're going to wish you had every
living soul fighting at your side no
matter your differences or past
conflicts John says my own men murdered
me for allowing the loud links through
the wall but I would do it again if I
knew it could help save the realm this
revelation stuns almost everyone in
attendance
Jamie apologizes to John for what has
happened to him and his family
and he swears he had nothing to do with
the red wedding or Ned Stark's death
Jamie wishes to speak with Varys because
Varys was there when Joffrey ordered Ned
Stark's execution it was Geoffrey's
decision alone to their disbelief Varys
is not in the room no one has seen him
since he walked away from the main gate
when Jaime arrived and said Cersei
wasn't sending men as everyone in the
Hall is still trying to grasp the
situation at hand
in comes bran stark Jaime begins to
shift his stance in his right arm begins
to tremble bran is being pushed into the
hall by his sister Arya Stark
she puts his brand next to John and
Sansa then Arya looks up at Jaime and
she says what's wrong it looks like you
have just seen a ghost
Jaime doesn't say anything but his arm
is still trembling
aurilla says you might not remember me
Kingslayer
but I remember you I remember your
friend bran also you were both at the
twins celebrating with Walder Frey after
you had my uncle the blackfish murdered
aurilla then pulls something from her
she puts on the face of the serving girl
and says remember me Jamie's eyes begin
to fill up with water
several men stand up and walk up behind
Jamie and bran with their swords drawn
Aria pulls out her dagger she begins to
spin it around in her hand the tension
in the room is reaching a boiling point
arya says sir jamie is there anything
else you have done to my family that we
should know about Jamie doesn't say a
word but he looks at bran and he sees
that bran was already looking at him
Jamie can feel brains eyes peering deep
into his soul deep into his past jamie
is still silent
struggling to find the right words to
say but then bran finally says something
brain says I know tyrion is beginning to
feel just as many eyes on him as his
brother Jamie men are beginning to
mutter curses and he can hear em just as
much as Kingslayer Tyrion realizes he is
just as likely to die alongside Jamie
Lord Glover stands up he tells bran to
tell everyone what he knows he says what
have you seen bran what have you heard
about the Kingslayer
Bran's eyes and never leave Jamie Sean's
a stands up and demands someone to speak
Jamie looks at Sansa he is on the verge
of a breakdown Jamie says no need my
lady I will tell you everything Jamie
walks into the center of the room he is
ready to admit his guilt of all his past
crimes Jamie looks at all the stark
children and begins by saying I am truly
sorry I do not expect anyone to forgive
me for what I am about to say
Tyrion looks at bran he seemed certain
he knows what is coming next deep down
he always knew it was true and deep down
he always knew he could die for the
crimes done by his family as Jamie
begins to continue with his confessions
the sound of a horn sends shivers down
everyone's spine the sound was so loud
it could probably wake the dead
Winterfell Hall erupts in chaos
everyone's worst fear has just became a
reality the army of the Dead has arrived
Jon immediately orders everyone who is
not willing to fight to get under
around and flee John had prepared for
this so he had the secret passages
mapped out for an escape route then he
tells torment in the Hound to light the
pitch in the trenches John hands Jamie
widow's wail he says if you have any
shred of Honor left come prove it and
fight with me when they get outside they
enter a complete whiteout visibility is
no more than a few feet in front of
their faces John tells Daenerys to get
on the ground he doesn't want her at
risk now that she is pregnant but
Daenerys refuses to not see this fight
through she tells John if she doesn't
help none of them will survive anyway
she will not let vissarion's death
happen without delivering her own
justice to the night King John has no
option but to let her fight he knows how
badly her dragons are needed now
Daenerys mounts drogon and takes to the
sky but she can't see a thing nor can
she hear Viserion John gets to the top
of the main wall he looks out into the
storm hoping to get a glimpse of the
army of the Dead for a few moments he
can't see more than five feet in front
of him but then he starts to see the
faint glow of blue eyes off into the
distance he can't see their bodies but
he can see tens of thousands of blue
dots all around the castle most of the
forces were camped outside of the walls
so John hopes they can brace themselves
before their camp is overrun the snow is
so deep the Dothraki won't be able to
mount their horses bran attempts to warg
into the Ravens in order to send them
out into the storm to see where exactly
the night king is but the birds won't
take flight either the night king is too
close and powerful or the storm is too
severe but brain can't warg into the
Ravens then the screams of thousands of
dying men pierced through the storm like
a crack of thunder the battle has begun
the Great War is here John Snow the
Hound Jaime Lannister tormund grey worm
Jorah Mormont Ahri again jury and
several others exit the main gate and
head out into the storm the rest of the
pitch in the trenches is ignited
Winterfell was now enclosed in a ring of
fire
no one goes in and no one goes out their
destiny now lies ahead of them as
enter the battle the faint glow of red
and orange can be seen through the storm
drogon and reg all have found their
targets the knight King seems to have
sent his army forward first before he
decides to face two dragons with one it
is revealed that he has dozens of White
Walkers equipped with AI Spears along
with his giants that have ten-foot
Spears at some point during the battle
grey worm will be slain by a white
Walker he was able to kill one with his
dragons life spear but due to the
limited visibility he wasn't able to see
the others closing in on him nearly all
of the unsullied are killed in the first
wave of the attack along with thousands
of death racki men Brienne of Tarth leg
is badly wounded during the battle
torment and Jorah tried dragging her
back to the castle wall but they will
come under attack during the process and
tour men will be killed Jamie and John
are both injured during the battle also
Arya ends up surrounded by several
White's she is able to kill many of them
but if it wasn't for Jaime and John
shielding her she may have fallen as
well Daenerys is able to destroy
hundreds if not thousands of whites who
are drug on and reg all but the storm is
so bad it's nearly impossible to see
where all of them are coming from with
the amount of injuries they start to
fall back to the castle they are hoping
Daenerys can take out most of them while
they get the injured to safety meanwhile
on the other side of the castle two
Giants are carrying a huge boulder to
throw down into the flaming moat once
the rock is in place it will give them
something to climb over so they can
reach the castle and allow the whole
army to start scaling the walls or break
a gate then the knight King enters the
battle vissarion scream sounds much
louder than dragons or ray calls now
Daenerys attempts to have both dragons
land by the gate so they can put all of
the injured on the dragons and fly them
into the courtyard so they can get
underground when she lands drogue on
Ragle gets hit by an ice spear and it
rips right through his Wain causing him
to fly off erratically as everyone
boards drogue on the sound of a
seryeong's scream is getting closer and
his blue flame seems to be getting
brighter through the fall Daenerys
realizes she doesn't have much time to
react
and she has too many people on throw
going to try and engage the night king
now instead of dropping them off inside
the courtyard where the night king would
surely find them she takes off and
leaves the castle as they are flying
away hundreds of whites are climbing
over the rock and demote they will be
climbing the castle walls and moments
the nigh King appears to the storm and
the first thing he does is torch the
godswood the heart tree that has stood
for generations and generations is now
up in flames re folks that is actually
the end of episode three so it looks
like some of the battle is gonna pick
back up in episode 4 after everybody is
able to escape from Winterfell so it
should be interesting to see how things
kind of end let me know what you think
about this so far put all your comments
questions and stuff like that down below
in the comment section I want to thank
everybody for stopping by and watching
this video and I also want to thank
everyone on patreon who supports this
channel this video is already running
pretty long so I just want to end it
right here but thank you all I hope you
have a great day
I will see you soon with episode 4 bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]